Welcome to lesson four. Lesson four is all about authentication. This is
one of my favorite lessons, actually. We're going to build a complete log
in system, or learn how to build a complete log in system
rather. And then you're going to build a complete log in system for
your blog. So users can actually log in and register on the
blog that you've been working on so far. We're going to learn about
cookies, which is a little bit of information your browser stores to
know what user is logged into your blog. We're going to talk about passwords,
an hashing passwords, an how to store those securely in your database. An
we'll also just talk about hashing in
general, because it's a really handy little
tool that'll come up, many times throughout
your, programming career. It sounds simple but
it's actually quite complex. It'll be a lot a fun. So, let's get started.